the bottle cap challenge is taking over
everyone from Justin and Haley Bieber
Liz Oh a Blake Shelton and even Raya
Kari are doing it which is why we've
rounded them all up just for you John
Mayer and Jason Statham were two of the
first to participate both guys opted for
a slo-mo effect Diplo also pretty much
nailed it okay so while they were all
pretty flawless Shaq well kinda
massively failed
[Music]
[Music]
that had to have hurt Blake Shelton's
was also pretty funny
rogue one actor Donnie Yen also join the
fun popping off the cap while
blindfolded lizzo failed then succeeded
and then there's Justin Bieber who
nominated his wife and Tom Cruise to
also participate still unclear why the
beeps keeps calling out tom remember
that whole boxing thing tom has yet to
accept Justin's challenge the wife
hailey did
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie that was pretty
impressive though I think you'll agree
with me Mariah Carey is the real winner
here so good but really there's only one
thing left to do alright guys which
bottle cap challenge is your favorite
and who else do you want to make one let
me know and for all the latest on your
favorite celebs keep it locked to all
things
ét bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]